This video is brought to you by a news voice.
The news is broken almost all us media is owned by just a handful of big
corporations. Fake news is obviously a huge problem as well.
And finding something unbiased can be really hard.
News voice is revolutionizing the news landscape.
It's an app that gives you a personalized newsfeed by aggregating major new
sites,
as well as international and independent media giving some much needed balance.
Each new story shows multiple sources,
which are all tagged with their bias and perspective.
The news affects almost everything in our lives. What we hear and read shapes,
which persons we trust, what we eat, what we buy, how we vote,
and even how we think news voices created by its readers. As you can,
upvote stories that you find interesting. So more people will see them.
It's essentially a democratized platform for news. Plus it saves you time.
You get all the news and all the sources in one app so that you can be better
informed. Oh, and it's totally free. Anyway,
get started with news voice today for free through the link below it's available
on both Google play and the Apple app store. And let's get into the video
28th of August, 2020 Shinzo RB, the longest serving prime minister,
and one of the most powerful in Japan's entire democratic period announced that
he has taken the decision to resign. He did.
So just four days after becoming the longest serving prime minister in modern
Japanese history.
So why did he make that decision? Because Mr. Harvey,
65 has an incurable disease known as ulcerative colitis,
a disease that led to his resignation in his first term as prime minister in
2007. Of course, this time, things are a little bit different.
His situation does not seem to be as bad now as it was then,
but the disease has been compounded by a bad political phase,
a critical juncture in which one year before the elections,
his popularity and that of his political circle is for the first time at rock
bottom.
[Inaudible].
Friends when Jim, so Bay came to power at the end of 2012, he did.
So with two very clear objectives on the one hand,
carry out an economic revolution that would put an end to the eternal Japanese
crisis. Something that became popularly known as Abe Nomics.
And on the other hand to face the growing challenges in foreign policy,
Mr. Arby's particular wish was to enable the land of the rising sun to compete
with China's growing influence in the region and fast guarantee national
security. These two key objectives were not only Shinzo Arby's goals,
but the hope of practically the whole country. And so today,
eight years after his arrival in power and taking into account that we are
witnessing the end of any era.
I think there's time has come to ask ourselves some questions.
What is the state of Japan today and have all,
or at least the main goals set by Shinzo RBA back in 2012, being achieved well,
as we've told you previously, that's not the case.
Shinzo RB was unable to carry out his main objective.
And indeed his departure comes at a particularly tense time in terms of national
security. Let's take a look.
The awakening of Japan.
Friends in a past video here on visual politic,
we talked about the upside of Japanese economy.
The truth is that the last decade has not exactly been bad during this time.
The country has experienced somewhat of a revival. And indeed,
although it's hard to believe it's real GDP in per capita terms has increased at
practically the same rate as that of the United States.
And even more than that of countries such as France and the United Kingdom.
However, now the Corona virus crisis has changed.
Everything.
While Japan's health situation is holding up.
Its economic situation is worse than most developed countries.
You see the Japanese economy like most of the world's major economies has also
been hit hard, check it out.
Japan, GDP contracts, annualized 27.8% in April, June,
Corona virus, pandemic causes biggest quarterly fall and post-war periods.
However, Japan's problem goes much further than this.
This pandemic has come at a particularly delicate time,
even before things were made difficult by COVID-19.
The country was already in recession.
A range of factors contributed to it slump the conflict of South Korea,
the trade war between the United States and China.
And to top it off a rise in consumer taxes at the end of 2019,
had put the Japanese economy on the ropes. And then on top of that,
the coronavirus crisis
Give you an idea. The Japanese economic research center estimates that best.
If things go well,
the Japanese economy will not recover to the level of GDP it had in 2018 until
at least 2024. In other words, in terms of economic growth,
that's five years down the drain and that's the best case scenario.
In other words,
the coronavirus crisis has devoured all the economic growth achieved during RV's
years.
So let's just say that this is something that has hamstrung one of our main
goals for Japan to escape it's never-ending crisis. But wait a minute.
In spite of this, the truth is that during these years, Japan has changed a lot.
In fact.
If Shinzo Arba has done anything at all,
it's been to pave the way to a huge transformation of Japanese society in the
coming years. Well,
let me explain when this prime minister came to power in 2012,
and he put an economic plan on the table, economics,
which had three main facets on the one hand,
reviving the economy in a short term with a super expansive monetary policy and
increased public spending. Secondly,
to take advantage of this temporary inertia,
to carry out the great changes that would make growth possible in the longterm.
And you know what things didn't go backwards.
You too.
Bobby, who's been a champion of free trade agreements over the last eight years.
He has signed among others,
a very important free trade agreement with the European union and kept alive the
TTP. The Trans-Pacific free trade agreement,
despite the withdrawal of the United States by Donald Trump,
Japan has also reformed the agricultural sector until our arrival,
the most closed and protected sector in country above all.
He has driven enormous changes that have increased the working population,
even as the country's population is in decline.
Hang on a minute.
How on earth did they manage to get the workforce to grow when the country is
losing population?
Well.
By promoting the incorporation of women into the labor market,
through among other measures, government funded childcare facilities,
and new types of contracts that facilitate a better work-life balance,
the result is obvious,
but that's not all incentives have also been put in place for many retirees to
reenter the labor market and above all immigration has been boosted. In fact,
as we have already told you here on visual politic in this respect,
Japan has started to break one of its main stumbling blocks, being a country,
very hostile to immigration.
Something that could become key in a rapidly aging society, such as this one,
just to give you an idea between Arby's arrival at the end of 2012 and 2018,
the immigrant population in Japan has more than doubled. In fact,
today one in eight people who come of age in Tokyo were not born in the country
In April, 2019.
One of the most important reforms of Shinzo RV era came into force a new
immigration law that makes it much easier to work in the country and improves
the rights of the foreign population.
If we immerse ourselves in the numbers that the government puts forward,
it may not seem like much until we realize that we are in one of the most
historically hostile and closed countries in terms of immigration in one way or
another. The reform set in motion by Shinzo Arba is history.
Of course, the results have been very limited so far in 2019,
only 10% of immigration quota set by the government had arrived in the country.
Because.
Japan is still a very complicated country to work in.
Think about it for a moment long days,
a huge cultural leap and many misgivings about if not clear,
rejection of foreign workers who are often perceived as poor and a burden on the
state. Now let's be honest, unless you have a full wallet.
You're probably more comfortable in another country. And even in the other case,
if you are a qualified professional,
it is likely that the very long working days,
the few holidays and the obsessive work culture,
not likely to be that appealing to you, that at least is what the theory says.
And it's also backed up by the surveys on foreign skilled workers. In any case,
the issue now is that the Corona virus has sunk the popularity of the government
and put all this progress on.
Yes.
It is true in the battle against the virus.
Japan has done well with more than 125 million inhabitants.
It had only registered just over 60,000 positive cases and just under 1,300
deaths at the time of making this video,
these numbers are a far cry from the nightmare that has been and is being
experienced in other countries around the world,
just like Spain or the United States, Brazil, Mexico, or even Peru. However,
despite this,
the general feeling in the country is that the political leadership and faster,
more agile measures to further reduce the impact of this pandemic have been
lacking. And that is why the government's popularity has.
Plummeted.
Skip the whole pandemic story. We've all heard enough of that.
The truth is that beyond the management of this Corona virus,
the end of RBA zero is overshadowed by what has perhaps been a great personal
political failure. And also in some ways.
National one.
I am referring to the country's inability to guarantee national security in
regards to North Korea and also China because friends,
one of our base great political objectives was to amend article nine of the
Japanese constitution so that the country would abandon its pacifist policies.
And that has not been achieved. In fact,
despite having put all his weight behind it in recent years,
Japan's defense still suffers from basically the same problems it had when
Harvey came to power, listen up.
An increasingly complicated neighborhood.
Northeast Asia is becoming an increasingly dangerous community. For example,
let me ask you a question.
Do you think that the North Korean crisis is already water under the bridge?
Well, you are very, very wrong since May, 2019. That's just over a year.
The pong yang regime has conducted 33 missile tests,
including the simulation of a saturation attack.
This is an attack in which a lot of this Isles are launched on the same target
in order to exhaust the enemy's defenses.
Not only that North Korea began 2020 by announcing a tougher foreign policy
approach, including the possibility of resuming long range missile testing.
And of course it's not just North Korea,
China Shujing Ping's new China seems to be taking an increasingly expansionist
line while modernizing its armed forces.
Full speed.
Well,
China is an open confrontation with Japan over the control of the Senkaku Dow U
islands, a group of uninhabited islands located very close to Taiwan.
Some think tanks and pro government newspaper supported by Beijing are now also
questioning Japan sovereignty over the Island of Okinawa itself,
an Island with nearly one and a half million inhabitants.
That is key to Japan's defense.
Okinawa is also the most important us military base.
In the region.
Of course, as we mentioned,
all this is happening while the Chinese army has embarked on a huge program to
modernize its armed forces.
For example, estimates suggest that by the end of this decade, that is by 2030,
the Chinese air force could have up to 500 operational fifth generation
fighters, J 20 and J 31,
which would far exceed the projected fifth generation capability of Japan's air
force.
The land of the rising sun has signed off the acquisition of a fleet of 147
F 35 units,
which will make it the second largest fleet of this type of aircraft in the
world. We are talking about a gigantic program worth more than $20 billion,
but no, it's not just about the jet fighters,
amongst many other pieces of equipment.
The Chinese military is also developing a new generation of ballistic missiles,
including supersonic missiles,
a force that could shatter Japan's current defenses.
And there's more as Chinese general, Marshall Chan stated in 2016,
they are even developing a new long range stealth bomber.
And it is precisely because of this deployment.
That Shinzo RFA was always clear that his main goal is number one objective in
his second term as prime minister has to be to put an end to Japan's
institutional pacifism and to boast of Japan's decimated self-defense forces.
[Inaudible].
Progress has been made. We will certainly talk about it at length,
in a future video here on the channel under Arby's government,
the Japanese armed forces have bought new equipment and even set up their first
overseas military base in Djibouti. But in practice,
everything remains basically the same.
Let's say that Japan has not managed to develop autonomous systems against the
new threats. Its military budget remains relatively small,
almost seven times smaller than China's and Shinzo Arba has failed to push
through a change in article nine of the constitution to put an end to the
pacifist doctrine that has governed the country since the end of the second
world war.
One, aspiring sincerely to an international peace based on justice and order the
Japanese people forever renounce war as a sovereign rate of the nation and the
threat or use of force as a means of settling international disputes to,
in order to accomplish the aim of the proceeding, paragraph land,
sea and air forces, as well as other war potential will never be maintained.
The rate of belligerency of the state will not be recognized.
Article name of the Japanese constitution.
Well, things are not the same. In fact, they could potentially be even worse.
[Inaudible].
A bullwhip of Japanese defense has been its Alliance with the United States,
a country that maintains 78 military installations in the country.
These are facilities for which Japan pays nearly $4 billion a year,
over 8% of its entire military budget for decades.
The basic idea was that Japan would take over the defense while American forces
would take over the action. This is known as the shield and sword model,
Japan character shield, and United States, the sword. However,
the Trump administration has changed everything. Now,
the feeling in many countries like this is that they have to start taking care
of their own.
Business.
And friends.
It's not just that the Trump administration has cast doubt on America's
commitment to the land of the rising sun. As for example,
when it demanded that the Japanese government pay more money to keep us troops
on the ground as if Japan did not already fit almost 90% of the bill or as if
these deployments were not also advantageous for the United States itself. No,
it's not just that. There is also another issue.
[Inaudible].
You see,
following that shield and sword model and responding to the demands of the Trump
administration itself, some three or four years ago,
Japan decided to purchase the Lockheed Martin ages assure system for over
4 billion dots. A system that moves the ages,
warship based ballistic missile defense to land.
The idea was to compliment the two layers of Japan's current missile defense
system,
which consists of the sea level with seven ages destroyers and the land-based
Patriot missile system we've land-based installations.
It was the formula with which Japan wanted to protect itself from the North
Korean threat and a potential Chinese threat.
[Inaudible].
This past June,
2020 to everyone's surprise and in what has been one of his last great decisions
as prime minister Shinzo RB had this program thrown out, he canceled it.
June 15th, 20, 20 Japan, suspends ages,
assured deployment pointing to costs and technical issues.
The anti-missile system on which the United States had embarked them on simply
does not seem to serve much purpose. At least not for Japan's interests,
because of course, if we're talking about the interests of Lockheed Martin,
that's a different story.
When the government said that Japan needed, I just on the ground,
we already knew that missile defense was not effective in all situations.
Eventually it would take almost a decade to deploy.
I just assure in the meantime,
our adversaries would be developing more effective weapons designed to weaken
muscle defense. Hi,
go Saito professor at taco Shuko university and vice president of the Institute
of world studies.
2016 And 2017.
The validity of the anti-missile system was already greatly damaged when North
Korea simulated its first saturation attack a strategy that could apparently
overcome this entire system relatively easily.
And since then.
The development of missile technology and hypersonic attack vehicles that is
vehicles that operate at five times,
the speed of sound being carried out by countries,
such as China and Russia has brought to all the limitations of an anti-missile
system. Like the one the United States assaulted Japan into the spotlight.
And what can I say?
The feeling on the ground in Japan is that they increasingly feel American
politicians are treating them like some kind of cash cow and ATM machine to make
gold for the U S military industry.
But the fact is that all this leads us to a key question.
If Japan has suspended the anti-missile system,
how do they propose to defend themselves now?
Well.
He himself made this very clear last June 18th,
when he said the following at a press conference, we should.
Renew our discussion of adequate deterrence.
We need considering North Korea's missile technology that has advanced since the
time we introduced our missile defense systems.
The question is if we should stay within the boundary,
when enemy capability is dramatically advancing Shinzo Abbey.
The terrorists, that's the key word. In recent months,
the Japanese government has decided to open up this Pandora's box.
That of being able to equip the self-defense forces with sufficient military
capacity to attack an enemy preventatively,
if they feel they are at risk of being attacked.
[Inaudible].
In other words,
we are basically returning to the debate on article nine of the Japanese
constitution.
The problem is that today the vast majority of Japanese society is simply
against it.
69% Pose chains to Japanese.
Constitution's war renouncing, article name poll shows.
In short, this is the great failure of,
or at least the great political disappointment of Shinzo RB.
Not only has he failed to change the country's pacifist character,
he has also failed to prepare it to face the new threats.
And even now at the end of his term of office,
he has given up the anti-missile shield that is in terms of national security.
And despite this being a priority issue,
the country's structural weakness is almost as great as when are they came to
power in 2012, progress has been made,
and we will tell you about it in forthcoming videos, but in structural terms,
things have not been.
Proved, much.
Friends, shins, a Barbie and Gigi pink came to power at almost the same time.
The Japanese prime minister took the Baton barely a month after the Chinese
leader did his mission to make Japan rival the growing power of China.
There are clearly areas where he has not succeeded in this video.
We wanted to tell you how Japan has changed and how it has not changed under
Arby's leadership. But now it's your turn. What do you think Japan should do?
Will our base resignation undo the decision to break the U S missile shield,
leave your answers in the comments. So I really hope you've enjoyed this video.
Please hit like if you did, and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos.
And also this channel is possible because of Patrion and Allah patrons on that
platform,
please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll be seeing you in the next video.